okay guys but for real I know you're in
wedding planning mode are we really not
gonna see it on TV it's really gonna be
an East Coast non-televised non Mexico
wedding
it's definitely non Mexico yeah it's
probably not televised we made you
something I mean no like no happens but
we might take it into our own hands and
like show the fans and some other weird
way like we did with the story of us but
it's still 10 months away so there's a
lot of thinking to be done yeah we just
want the best wedding possible and
that's what we're planning right now so
we're just trying to put any outside
noise away so what is the wedding day
it's it's probably like the first two
weeks of August but we're not 100% sure
yet nothing's been signed well what is
set in stone do we have a dress what
else is on the books we have a dress we
definitely have the venue picked out
yeah it's not like official with them
and they put the deposit down yeah it's
under contract so we don't want to jinx
it yeah we think we have a wedding cake
maker Baker do you think we have had
never bleeding more news about that
coming up at some point yeah but yeah we
think we have our wedding cake maker
which is very exciting but it's cool
we're planning a New England wedding
it's you know my home state I love it
and real quick thoughts on Colton he's
about to start at all do you like him
his bad yeah we definitely like him as
bachelor they had three good choices
they really couldn't have gone wrong
this year and he's very he's very
friendly warm easy to talk to so the
girls should have a great time well
Colton loses mine who knows maybe I
think he's never gonna probably cry the
most out of any bachelor in the history
lot showed a lot of emotion with man :
cries I love that he cries though it's
no I want that - I like it - yeah
[Music]